this map shows the major infrastructure
of Saudi Aramco the world's most
profitable company the dark spots
clustered to the east are deep
reservoirs of oil and natural gas the
lifeblood of Aramco's business and the
global economy for nearly a century
Aramco soil has powered cars planes and
industries and electrified homes around
the world and 2018 the company produced
thirteen point six million barrels of
oil a day more than any other company
then in 2019 Aramco's IPO valued the
company at 1.7 trillion in the world's
biggest ever public offering but the
forces that propelled Aramco's growth
from a single well to the biggest
producer in the world are changing
underfoot and some analysts say the
company won't be able to sustain the
kind of growth that will need to keep
investors happy to understand these
changes you have to understand how a
Ramco got so big in the first place the
company was founded in the 1930s on a
barren tract of desert with no natural
River or body of water and little
vegetation it was completely pre-modern
I mean it really looked basically like
it had since the 1700s the 1800s the
kingdom's leader it bin saud was low on
cash to fund development so in 1933 he
struck a deal with an American oil
company Standard Oil of California or
SoCal won the right to search for oil
near the eastern coast in al-hasa five
years and several dry wells later SoCal
and its partner Texaco hit oil a lot of
it quickly well number seven was
producing commercial quantities around
4,000 barrels of crude oil a day workers
began construction on a pipeline to the
sea by spring of 1939 the SoCal tanker
DG Scofield docked at rasta nura and
filled its first shipment of oil to
leave Saudi Arabia for the global
markets
the country with nothing to sell had
found what everyone wanted to buy over
the following decades the American Group
found more and more mineral wealth
beneath the Saudi sand by 1970 that oil
would play a crucial role in a market
halfway around the world a market so big
it would lift Aramco's profits and push
Saudi Arabia to alter the future of oil
markets everywhere what happened is that
in 1970 Texas tapped out after more than
a century of growth US oil production
began to fall at the time Americans were
driving to work in gas guzzlers like
these the average fuel consumption for
this type of vehicle was thirteen and a
half miles per gallon to fuel these cars
the u.s. turned overseas you can see it
on this chart which shows the country's
imports of crude oil a Ramco still an
American company had plenty of oil to
sell Walt said that between 1972 and
1973 production grew from 5.4 million to
8.4 million barrels a day according to
Aramco in 1971 shipments of crude oil
and petroleum products from Rosten era
had surpassed 1 billion barrels a year
Saudi Arabia and other oil-producing
nations took notice of all this demand
OPEC this Organization of Petroleum
Exporting companies which had been
created in the 60s but didn't do
anything for years it was essentially
negotiate with the big international oil
companies like Exxon and BP and shell
and they would negotiate a price for oil
and they were basically selling all of
their oils to these international
companies that had distribution outlets
around the world and 1973 comes along
and the countries say you know what we
know what's happening with demand we
know that we're supplying most of your
market we need a higher price for oil
when OPEC tried to raise prices the
international companies said no so Saudi
Arabia's oil minister Ahmad Zaki Yamani
took a different approach right at that
exact same time was the arab-israeli war
and a lot of the countries in OPEC
wanted to basically help out their
fellow Arab countries
raising the price of oil and both
embargoing it to the countries that were
helping israel namely the United States
and its allies the Saudis were actually
the least interested in doing this but
once it became clear that they could
negotiate an increase in the price of
oil yamani looked at the situation he
said we can use this political situation
to our advantage here's your money in
December of 1973 when the Israelis
accept to withdraw from the occupied
territories and the US government
guarantees their decision then
immediately we can lift the embargo this
happen any time the plan worked
this chart shows the u.s. price for oil
before and after the embargo President
Nixon said the gas crisis has dissolved
into a problem but it's a problem
millions of motorists are still trying
to cope with and long lines at their
local gas stations while America was
reeling from the price shock Saudi
Arabia was making plans to increase its
control of a ram cattle that year the
kingdom said a deal to buy 25 percent of
the company and that was really when the
tables turned and it was very clear that
it was no longer these big international
oil companies it was no longer the
Americans it was the Saudis that
controlled their oil and controlled
their commodity and shortly after that
in 1974 they negotiated to buy another
percentage of the company in 1976 they
had more negotiations that led to them
eventually completing the purchase for
all of Aramco in 1980
Aramco is now fully owned by the Saudi
state from this point forward
Saudi Arabia along with OPEC would exert
enormous control over the price of oil
everywhere in the early 80s the company
set forth on a period of rapid expansion
that would take a Ramco beyond the
kingdom's oil fields and borders to new
markets around the world
Alley on the e me became the first Saudi
CEO of the company so it was his vision
that diversified and really integrated
the company and turned it into something
that could make money in all parts of
the value chain not just the pumping new
oil out of the ground so they first went
to Korea and they negotiated with the
South Koreans and they started a joint
oil refinery called S oil in South Korea
they also negotiated in Japan and they
also have a big oil storage facility in
Japan then finally they got to China and
they have several joint ventures in
China for refineries and petrochemicals
the timing was right to capitalize on a
surge and demand for oil here's a look
at China's GDP over those decades they
set up in Asia at exactly the moment
when Asia took off as a consumer and
they were really well positioned and in
fact Saudi Arabia is currently the
largest oil supplier to China right now
by the 2000 it was a global conglomerate
positioned to profit from a historic
rally and oil prices supply disruptions
in the Middle East and demand in
emerging markets like India drove the
price to new heights price spikes are
becoming a way of life in the United
States geopolitical certainty in a
number of countries in the Middle East
and Africa will continue to keep markets
on edge gas prices are hitting new highs
we got a live with it they're going to
keep going up in 2008 the price of oil
hit a record high of a hundred and forty
seven dollars in the decades since that
peak many of the factors that led to a
ram COEs rise have shifted for one the
u.s. came back online as a major oil
producer by 2008 US producers had found
new ways to extract oil from places they
had thought were tapped out as well as
some new areas production surged this is
nanzen-ji Soleri a former Aramco
executive what the US producers have
Dondo is extraordinary and with the
benefit of new engineering capabilities
especially the fracking capabilities
they're able to produce significant
amount
of a boil and today you look at the US
production it's approaching 13 million
barrels per day meanwhile cars and homes
had become more efficient curbing growth
in demand the average fuel economy for
new cars in the United States is now
closer to 25 miles per gallon that's
almost twice what it was in 1970 and at
the same time buyers have slowly started
shifting toward cleaner energy sources
and the new world is all about clean
BTUs clean energy so Aramco now has to
compete in the clean BTU era nobody in
the industry including the most
successful IOC's including the
unconventionals they cannot say oh we're
totally blind to what's going on as far
as global warming as far as co2
emissions or greenhouse emissions that
somebody else's a problem there is not
an answer anymore
investors are pumping cash into assets
deemed more environmentally friendly
such as so-called ESG funds which focus
on environmental social and governance
factors investors say all of these
factors have threatened oil stocks
here's the performance of oil stocks
compared to the broader market this was
the stage being set in 2016 when Aramco
said it was considering an IPO as part
of an effort to diversify the company's
economy beyond oil after setbacks Aramco
launched its IPO in 2019 selling 1.5% of
itself on the Tata wool in Riyadh mostly
to Saudi investors it's unclear if the
company will sell more on international
markets and reach the 5% like it had
planned